I have come here to chew bubblegum and
kick ass okay and it's time once again
for yet another 13 o'clock movie
retrospective yeah this one is they live
a classic yeah JOHN CARTER yeah we've
done a lot of John Carpenter movies on
this show he's one of my favorite
directors he is a yeah I really like a
lot of his yes and you know we own a lot
of his movies that's probably why I here
we've done so many of them making a
whole collection of him on blu-ray
yeah all of his good stuff though
there's you know and it wasn't too big
and like big trouble little China
vampires
we'll see okay one time time I didn't
like what was the one with the with the
green goo in the canister green goo in
the canister Prince of Darkness yeah
yeah that's right I wasn't too crazy
about that one yeah a little weird yeah
well it was a little uneven I thought it
was kind of a cool idea but I don't
think it was that well executed well
John Carpenter's entire career I think
is a little uneven
he has hits and he has misses yeah and I
think we talked about that last time
like I feel like you know 75 80 percent
maybe 90 percent of his movies are good
but then there's like a handful that I'm
just counting they live was a hit he
asked me I think that it was a weird
mixture of a really good story good
acting and a really low budget yeah as
movie was made for him like nothing I
think it was like less than three
million dollars that's just three
million and I think it grows like 13
million at the box-office yeah it was it
was a number one like the number one
movie for a couple weeks in a row came
out in 1988 yeah and the interesting
thing about this is that John Carpenter
I mean he pretty much did he like did he
write the main role with Roddy Piper in
mind I think
you did because I guess John Carpenter
was like a big wrestling fan yeah he
knew and he had met Piper like backstage
you met him to them um I didn't meet him
I saw him s talking at a horror
convention oh yeah and it was funny
because it was a horror convention so I
expected everyone to ask him about they
live but everybody asked him about
wrestling yeah so I was just kind of
like I don't watch wrestling so I had no
idea what they were talking about but
well the interesting thing about Roddy
Piper in this is that like he's not a
good actor I don't think I'd go that far
but he's good in this because he's like
an everyman like he's just like a
regular person like you don't get the
sense that he's acting so much as you're
just kind of filming someone like going
about their regular day carpenter knew
him carpenter said that he was just like
a nice everyday guy yeah everybody could
relate to and it wasn't any pretension
in rowdy yeah Piper was just a nice guy
and he didn't really have to do a whole
lot of acting because he was kind of
playing himself yeah because I think and
I think again that's probably why John
Carpenter picked him for this role
because one he seems because we listen
to we have the blu-ray of it and we
listen to the commentary with Roddy
Piper and John Carpenter and like you
said Roddy Piper seems like a super nice
man like super humble and all this other
stuff very self-deprecating very funny
he had actually had a lot of problems of
his own like with homelessness and
things like that so he could relate to
this character I think and he didn't
really have to stretch all that much to
play this role yeah and this had another
one of my favourite actors in theirs
name was Keith David yeah alright now
Keith David was the black guy from the
thing yeah you know he played child's
and child's was kind of like he was kind
of co-starring with the crustle yes so
there's like there's this connection
between the crustle
and David Keith Dave and you know if you
listen to our last one yeah we talked
about six degrees of crustle yes right
you have a situation where you have you
have Keith David you have John Carpenter
and the shadow of crustle is a relation
there so he's not close to like Russell
isn't in it but he's kind of
in spirit he's in it in spirit that's
not that's that's how I see it this is
how it's seen through the eyes of Ross
part of mine the eyes of God like
Russell bromance crustle Bass bromance I
know this is gonna become a like a
running joke on the show just like our
where's that raccoon and yeah Matt said
I could this will be like every episode
now you have to bring up Russell in some
way well it doesn't matter like how
labyrinthine the connection is Welk
Russell crustle also worked with Quentin
Tarantino and I went to school Quinn
tangina so you're really part of the
crosses fear Wow
it's likely not the chronosphere but the
cross the sphere if you could like see
like my mind is being blown right now
just like scanners that's right yeah you
didn't know that no I didn't know no so
now I guess so that's my so that's I
guess that's my association with Russell
T that's right I've related through you
you're related to crustle through me so
yeah so Keith David was in the thing and
John Carpenter liked him so much that he
wrote the role of Frank yeah in they
live specifically for Keith David also
Keith and Piper actually became good
friends on this yeah Keith David kind of
taught Roddy kind of how to act and they
would like go to lunch together in
character and just pretend like they
were their characters you know I mean
for like days on end so evidently there
was kind of like some male bonding going
on in the real world between Keith David
and Roddy Piper which is that's kind of
cool wait and yeah that's one of the
things that I thought was really cool
about listening to the commentary on
this movie was that Roddy Piper I mean
he took this acting job very seriously
and he was like you know he wanted all
the tips people could give him and he
was like always asking John Carper he's
always asking Keith David what should i
do how should I do this and stuff like
that so like I said he's like a very
humble duty wasn't cocky at all um you
know he knew that he was you know that
he didn't have the acting chops that
maybe some of the other people on the
movie had and so he was like constantly
asking for advice and stuff like that
but like I said I think his lack of
acting experience kind of lent something
to this movie yeah actually watching
this movie with the commentaries awesome
yeah with
the piper and yeah oh man I did terrible
right there you know no man you did fine
yeah you didn't do well I wouldn't put
it in there you know it was well it's so
funny because I can see like I could
never I don't think I would ever make a
good actor because I'm too like
self-conscious yeah
and I can imagine like how [ __ ]
horrifying it must be to like have to
watch yourself on screen I don't even
like listening to our own podcast back
because I don't really like listening to
myself talk so it's like if you had to
see your big ass face like up on the
movie screen and stuff like oh my god I
would hate that
and I would just I would be just like
Roddy Piper on that [ __ ] I just be
like oh my god I suck so bad I can't
even like you know I mean it would be
like that but he doesn't suck he's
awesome in this yeah there's a lot this
movie's just awesome cuz there's a lot
of like really classic memes in it you
know putting the glasses on yeah you
know I mean that it really made a
college cultural impact I think that was
kind of greater than its yeah then its
box office would have suggested I guess
yeah if you don't know the premise this
is about a guy who's homeless and he
ends up at a homeless shelter this
church and this church has something
clandestine going on in it Roddy Piper
plays a guy his name is never mentioned
in the film but he's accredited as nada
yeah which means nothing and in Spanish
he goes into this church and he finds
these boxes of sunglasses that are being
made in this church and he can hear like
in other rooms revolutionaries talking
you know how we're gonna get this to the
people but later on he steals a Pete
pair of those glasses and later on he
puts them on him and he puts them on he
sees in black and white and he sees that
all the ads have all these subliminal
messages all the TVs are given these
subliminal messages and it's things like
sleep you know it says his form conform
yeah
Marian reproduce those that's right all
that all the dollar bills said this is
your god yeah and then he finds out that
some of the people are not people that
there's a me there like an alien
they look they look kind of like skulls
and yeah what's carpenter calls him
ghouls yeah cuz I guess they're kind of
like the Living Dead you know I mean
yeah they're the people that suck the
life out of you yeah and this was
actually the kernel of the story
actually came from a sci-fi story called
eight o'clock in the morning and it was
actually published in the 60s now
carpenter kind of took it in his own
direction because in the original story
I have not read it but according to like
I was a comic book um no well it started
out as a short story and then it was
adapted like in a comic like later on
and actually it's kind of different it's
um it has to do with a guy who's put
into a trance by a stage hypnotist and
then when he wakes up he realizes that
all of the human race has been
hypnotized by aliens and that the aliens
are controlling humans horrible monsters
yeah and I think the original story only
takes place in one day the guy goes on a
shooting rampage yeah shooting all these
horrible monsters of course you know
nobody else sees these monsters right so
it's being you know everybody thinks
it's just a mass shooting mass murderer
going on right and you're not really
sure whether or not he's imagining these
monsters or if these where as in they
live it's pretty clear that the monsters
the monsters exist because as soon as
you put the glasses on or later on they
make contact lenses that do the same
thing you know it's pretty clear that
these people that look like humans some
of them are aliens now one thing that
that always kind of like maybe I don't
know I don't want to say it bothers me
about this movie but here's the thing
okay so nada discovers like kind of
accidentally through coming across the
sunglasses and stuff like that that when
he puts the glasses on he can see all
the subliminal messages he can see all
the propaganda he can see the people
that are aliens now I try to put myself
in the shoes of the person I said now if
I put on a pair of sunglasses and
suddenly saw that I would not
immediately think that I was seeing
reality I would think these are tricks
and glasses I mean in that the first
thing
think yeah but he was taking them on and
off and he was really verifying it that
they did work I guess so and then he
started actually talking to the aliens
making fun of the boy you are ugly yeah
and then they reported him remember they
got with the watch we have one of neckin
see yeah but he ends up going back to
the homeless calf and he hooks up with
Keith David who's playing a character
named Frank
yeah who's his buddy like on the
construction site we're on some work now
a nada had just gone on this shooting
rampage and some of the aliens that he
killed were alien cops yeah so you know
he's wanted by the law
he goes back to the camp and he tries to
get his buddy
tries to get his buddy Frank to put the
glasses on to see right and he won't put
them on which yeah it's like a somebody
get out of here no I don't wanna put on
the glasses and they get this long huge
fight scene yeah it's like six minutes
long probably the longest fight scenes
and it is funny yeah you know and and
and it's pretty good
and the idea wasn't during the
commentary you find out that it was kind
of trope of the white man fighting to
put the glasses on the black man to show
them to show him who the real oppressor
was right and you know that they
actually said that so it wasn't just you
know it just didn't look that way that's
the way it was intended it's pretty cool
ya know that but the fight scene in
there is like famous just because it
goes on for like a ridiculously long
time it's like you think it's over and
then it starts back up again these like
all these wrestling moves right and
evidently they practiced it for like
three weeks so it's like super
choreographed it looks really good yeah
and these two guys are like clearly
really like kind of beating the [ __ ]
you know Piper said that you said that
Keith David wasn't really a skilled
wrestler and wrestlers can can pull
punches and they're fake fighters yeah
they can do that without hurting each
other he said that said that Keith was
actually hurting him I think a couple
yeah yes but you know that he did get
hurt but there are you know like you
can't really see obviously in the movie
but some of the like pavement like on
the on the ground of the alley where
they're fighting is like that is like
it's kind of soft yes yeah so like when
they hit it it doesn't hurt them and
stuff like that but still I mean it you
can tell that they really use like some
real-life wrestling moves and [ __ ] like
that
but I think that fight scene is just
like so iconic just because it goes on
for Sicilies it's almost like I don't
know it's like this weird absurdist joke
and I'm just like just put the [ __ ]
glasses on just make him happy Rick and
eventually he puts the glasses on and he
sees he sees what's going on and he's
trying to go WOW you know it's true that
type of deal and they hook up with the
rebellion yeah that's trying to
overthrow these aliens and they end up
being on a mission where they're gonna
go into this television station and get
to the roof and destroy this transmitter
and this transmitter is with
broadcasting the signal that cloaks all
these aliens right yeah locusts all this
subliminal messaging on the on the
television screens and in the you know
all the billboards so if they can blow
up that transmitter everyone can see
then everyone will be able to see who's
the alien Raza and they've you know of
course eventually get it done and you
know I'm not gonna really spoil
everything if you haven't seen it go see
him it's a really good movie I would say
not quite as cool as escape from New
York but it has its own mojo it has it
something it's a totally different kind
of movie than it then escape from New
York it's like I don't know what it is
it's like this really I guess it's
marginally sci-fi I suppose but it's
kind of a commentary - yeah it's like a
political satire kind of also but it's
like one thing I have to say that I I
mean I know that you know it was made in
1988 and the kind of what is that noise
yeah she's in the closet oh this kid
yeah yes peep
she's gonna come right back in even long
so like it was made in 1988 so
some people might think of the aliens
look weird or look stupid or whatever
because they're real exact phrase they
are like low-tech but there's some kind
of like weird charm about there's like
these bright red and blue colors it's
like it looks like movies and also fun
fact almost all the goals that you see
in that movie were played by one guy
like because he was the one that had all
the makeup on and the appliances and
they said hey put on this fur coat and
be a lady and put on this put on a cop
uniform put on it so every pretty much
every time you see a ghoul of that movie
it's the same dude yeah I think this
movie is what inspired that guy to
believe into reptilians you know yeah
David Icke earri whatever his name is
right maybe he thought this was the
documentary yeah he thought I was dying
now I also now David Hickey did the
reptilian things in the New World Order
crap and really I think that evolved
into the kind of the Alex Jones idea of
the globalists because you find out that
this you find out that this is an alien
effort to swallow up all the nations of
the earth and put them under their
dominion and they're doing it for profit
yeah they're like it's basically like
yuppie aliens like all of it all the
yuppies that you see are aliens
basically yeah all the right every time
you see a rich person in real life you
put the glasses on and they're the
aliens yeah and then there are also some
humans too that are like working for
agents later like the character of
should I spoil it uh-uh no okay yeah but
you know some of the either humans
working with there are humans that know
about it and that are working with them
so they're like traitors right and there
are a couple of those in the movie The
Carpenters did say that real-life events
inspired him to write this film in the
commentary he's saying that it was based
upon like Reaganomics and he said that
these are he based his people on
Republicans like you know hardcore
capitalist but there's a lot of
controversy about who it is he's talking
about you can interpret it many
different ways that's kind of left open
to to interpretation some people are
gonna say that it's the reptilians or
the globalists or international
communists some people even say this
Jews that the weather is talking about
but I think it's more like more like the
Alex Jones concept of
globalists that's what I think well it's
just rich elitist rich elites that are
trying to manipulate the global system
to get rid of country sovereignty and
sovereignty is what calm protects
individual citizens and guarantees their
rights so yeah international crony
capitalism may be international
communism you can interpret it any way
any way you want to I guess anything
that's bad and yeah well and like I said
these they're definitely aliens they're
definitely like controlling the earth
for some purpose I don't think they
really specify what the aliens just
problem is or what they want you know
they're just pretty much exploiting
humans on the planet maybe they do it to
other planets we don't really know but
there are they do have like little
drones that look like 50 50s era flying
sauce it was little electric guys
actually movie the other day you said
something that was really interesting is
that cuz I said and I was getting to
this before and then we kind of got off
track but I said one of the things that
kind of bothers me about the movie is
that it would take me a while to get to
the point where Jon nada gets to like
almost immediately like oh like and at
maybe an hour like after he first puts
the sunglasses sunglasses on like he's
shooting up yeah he's already he's
already like running around doing a
shooting spree and we should say to that
it's like he shoots two cops I mean he
can see that they're aliens yeah you
know fair enough but then like he goes
into a bank with with guns with guns and
he's like you know and he says the
famous line you know I'm here to that's
the famous line from that and then he
just starts shooting now there are
humans in this Bank to not everyone in
there as aliens run so I kind of feel
like that was a tad irresponsible
because like you could have like hurt
some innocent people like it was the
macho 80s I guess is however much of you
see aliens you just shoot him yeah I
mean I think that was kind of one thing
that bothered me it just seemed to quick
like that he just like went from like
hey look I put on these sunglasses and
there's aliens in five minutes later
he's just like shooting [ __ ] up
at least a seen that way in the movie he
was seeing the aliens he was talking to
the aliens and saying how ugly that they
were and then they reported him for
being able to see right yeah the cops
pulled up to him and said look maybe we
can you know we can settle this
peaceably yeah there's to be something
in in this for you in other words they
were that the cops were asking him to
sell out right that he was gonna join
the team and they were gonna arrest him
and he didn't you know he's this kind of
pigheaded about it he didn't want to go
with them and got into a fight he got
one of the cops guns and just shot yeah
shot him both and then he goes on on a
shooting rampage yeah and to the people
who don't have these glasses on he just
looks like a madman shooting the places
that's what I was thinking because no I
mean other than like a small contingent
of people like the people that were in
the church like making the glasses and
stuff like that like a small band of
rebels nobody else knows that some of
these people are alien so to their minds
like here's just a crazy dude like
walking into a bank and just like
shooting yeah well dead and you know and
it just seemed like yeah you need to get
rid of the aliens yeah you need to do
that kind of [ __ ] but you know one you
could have accidentally shot some humans
you know - they're scaring the [ __ ] out
of everybody it's a movie though and
there's you know and Piper's just
planned on every man yeah and then every
man isn't necessarily the brightest man
that like one of my very favorite things
is like when he first put on the glasses
and he's kind of walking around and he
goes in like a grocery store or
convenience or something like that and
then he looks at like some politician on
TV and he's an alien because I knew it
he says yeah figures would be something
like this just like he's just kind of
deadpan he's like yeah that's
I've noted the commentaries I watched a
commentary from Keith David yeah no yeah
yeah yeah the place Franken this and
Keith David was he was actually very
suspicious when this movie came out he
liked it you know he says this is a
great football but he goes
boy it must have pissed off some
important people because it wasn't in
the theaters for very long even though
it was like the number one movie Friday
it was the number one movie for two
weeks or three weeks or something like
so the first came Keith David said that
somebody up there didn't like that movie
they got it as quick you know it's I
think in the ensuing years like I said
even though it was kind of a hit at the
time you know it only cost like less
than three million to make it ended up
making about 13 million I guess a box
office said it might have made more
sense they're not talking about a film
here you're talking to flick yeah like a
flick that has a message I love it yeah
I really like it there is there really
is like some kind of it has its own vibe
about it is homogeneous a weird little
movie it is it's you know a blues
soundtrack yeah soundtrack but yeah it
just has this kind of cool little vibe
that's kind of unlike most of carpenters
other movies I can't really think of one
of his other movies that's that's
similar I don't know I got it on blu-ray
it still looks great it stood the test
of time
yeah it really excellent flick and like
I said it's really I mean despite not
being as big a film like another sci-fi
film like an aliens or something like
that felt like everyone's seen it seems
like a smaller film than that but in a
way it seems like it's really kind of
gotten into the cultural fabric in a way
that maybe some other sci-fi guys
haven't gotten it it lives on in
Infowars and alex jones i think it does
i think i think that inspired a lot of a
lot of what alex jones does yeah i think
i had to do with reptilians and all that
yeah yeah alright and I guess that'll do
it for our review of they live another
John Carpenter movie we really need to
start doing some other directors what
did well yeah but I mean we've done so
many John Carpenter really
my movies I know but we've only done one
David Cronenberg we need you more David
Cronenberg what I got I got to do any
David Lynch and get more key I gotta get
more crud Cronenberg movies yeah well
because I'm gonna buy it on blu-ray I
kind of rebuild my blu-ray arsenal so
remember if you like the show please
remember to Like share subscribe on all
your social media share with your
friends all that other stuff and also
remember that we have a patreon at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast I
think and so go and check that out also
if you want to give a one-time donation
to have a monthly donation like you do
on patreon then you can go to the blog
which is at 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's like a little
PayPal link in the sidebar so you can
click on that and give us a buck or two
or even more bucks if you want you know
that's pretty cool like give a one-time
donation for the show and stay tuned for
more movie reviews and also stay tuned
for our special Halloween episode coming
up this Tuesday which is gonna be like
all Reeder spooky stories and you know
stories I've already seen the stuff you
put together that's gonna be awesome
yeah reader personal designs and stuff
like that yeah we have like kind of fun
little video clips and all that kind of
neat stuff so keep an eye out for that
also keep an eye out for us at spooky
Empire this coming weekend yeah we will
be there selling books and on several of
the panels and all kind of you have a
few fans showing up yeah so we will see
you guys there and until next time see
ya